alors oui toi mon cher prisonniers suite
il s'est commencé j'ai l'impression que
pour vous la guerre de sécession à ccc
si on avait dû répondre
ça s'est su mais dites moi maintenant
que vous êtes sont entre nos mains
vous n'avez rien à déclarer conti a chez
nous entre les sudistes
on avait été plus nombreux il est bien
vous autres les nordistes vous auriez
bel et bien plus important est ce que
vous répondriez ce que vous venez de
terrain joue enfin pourquoi que j'aurais
peut-être fait que si les sudistes
il avait déplu l'ombre et bienvenue lors
dit mon dieu il a révélé via un prêt
d'un printemps mais avez vous
l'impression blitz a alors dit qu'elle
en dise n'importe quel nordiste annonce
abonde par vous vous êtes caporal non à
la musette cirque et un sergent nordiste
vous auriez le tour de répéter votre
peut-il être multiples moi je la mets
légitime et 6 et 10 nivalle étaient plus
nombreux et la pâtée
et tiens je ne suis pas fier chant et
bien ça arrange tout je suis là chez les
grands ça n'arrange rien du tout et en
général prof vous sauriez la pétanque
aux balivernes
ah je ferai pas des bêtises de benjamin
ça serait culotté là ça se serait
d'abord smartphones y ait dans la
conversation je ne dis pas le glissement
que six vise les véhicules et appâter
les 45 minutes pour changer de compte
sinon kg je vous fais plus attention
oui la série à a
les gars je vous avez joué vous
réfléchissez buts à dix jours a pas la
victoire nordiste
permettez nous à présent pré montbronn
toi ou en famille et avec ça y est c'est
le bisou l'idole sauvage riou chatouille
lohan croit maintenant que vous êtes
démontre un content on l'a échappé belle
comment ça on l'a échappé belle si ces
salopards de sudistes il avait été plus
nombreux nous autres les nordistes on
prend le bel et bien la pente et vous
savez